Jeff Dunham well a great many people see
you as a hero there are some who'd
prefer the word vigilante the Russos you
know they make human stories with the
superhero feel as opposed to a super hit
movie with you know human touches cap to
Winter Soldier was a bit of a departure
I'm really trying to make its own mark
and they've kind of reinvented it again
we need to go in a radical direction if
we were gonna do another captain america
film so we were strongly advocating for
a civil war storyline we wanted
everybody to be both protagonists and
antagonists captain you seem a little
defensive well it's been a long day it's
not villain versus hero its friends it's
family that's what makes us good
conflict in this film everything's
changed this doesn't have to end in a
fight Tony you just started a war well
you know you got five on five people
coming together and just chaos a little
bit of stunt stuff some walk out some
don't I tried to be cool with it and be
like odd it don't matter to me but I was
I was high-fiving myself all day how was
I others as bananas I really do have a
strangely serious investment in these
films it's not going to be entirely
predictable characters are going to make
choices that surprise you the comic
books were really wonderful pieces of
literature I think that Marvel likes to
keep the fans excited guessing curious
all that stuff well I think we're all
good and bad in this film Downey is
playing a much darker version of Tony
Stark he's ever played and he's just
crushing it
hey youtubers is charlie don't you just
love listening to characters explain why
they're going to be [ __ ] in a new
film up front like okay this is gonna be
a lot of fun I'm going to be a total
[ __ ] but you're gonna love it
initially they always knew there was
going to be a third Captain America film
it was always planned as a trilogy it's
one of their most successful franchises
of course they're going to do a third
film but because the third Iron Man film
was originally intended to kind of close
that franchise down robert downey jr's
future at Marvel was uncertain they made
the decision to just use him in other
movies rather than try and do more solo
Iron Man films which I think was the
right call to make in civil war just
happened to be a really good opportunity
for a captain america film so marvel
civil war became captain america civil
war still a captain america film that a
really good opportunity to shake their
characters up even if you haven't read
comic books award they explain some of
these clips we take a much darker path
with some of these characters and i feel
like some of the Marvel actors do read
the comics some of them are more comic
book literate than others but even the
ones that have absolutely no idea what
happened in comic books of war the
producers the writers went to the actors
and said okay so good news bad news in
this film bad news is you're going to be
fighting this character here so half of
the audience probably isn't going to
like you at the end of the movie the
good news is is that you won't have to
be the same boring character that you
are in every single movie the job of the
writers and why they're doing some
reshoots they're doing reshoots on
Captain America Civil War that I'll
explain in just a second is to make
those characters that go dark you know
take the unpopular position seemed just
as likable as characters like Captain
America who will always have the moral
high ground no matter what decision he
makes characters likability like Iron
Man for instance really just depends on
the context of the scenes which is why
they actually just announced a reshoot
that they're doing they're adding a
character to the movie which seems kind
of late so maybe they already shot it
and they just waited 10 ounce until now
but alfre woodard is actually playing a
character who lost her son to psycho via
she's supposedly almost tackles Tony
Stark with her grief in public just
providing some context for why Tony
Stark feels like they need to put limits
on what the Avengers do a grieving
mother attacks him so it all just
becomes so much more real for him in a
way that it wasn't before unexpected WTF
though Alfre Woodard is actually playing
one of the main villains for Luke Cage
on the Netflix series
what does that mean for movie TV
crossovers she's playing two completely
different characters in the movies than
she is on the TV shows well one there's
the theory is that Marvel's TV division
and their movie division are moving in
completely different directions they're
less connected than they were before
which i think is likely I think they
just found a really amazing actor and
they wanted to use her and they're just
like please don't pay attention to the
fact that she's playing a completely
different character on this other series
so it's not like the movies are slapping
the TV shows in the face or anything
like that but this isn't the first time
this has happened there's an actor on
agent Carter who played a different
character in an Avengers film so there
are actors that both the TV shows and
the movies will use in completely
different roles and it's not necessarily
an indictment of the idea that
everything is connected but on the same
coin you may have noticed that a lot of
the TV actors have stopped saying
everything is connected as if they're
trying to downplay that like yeah
everything is connected but not really
as connected as you want it to be which
i think is kind of funny I think one of
the strikes and DC's favor is that up
front they were like we are definitely
not connecting to the TV shows so you're
not really disappointed when the movies
donate dollars the TV shows because they
told you that was the law of the land
it's a little more disappointing when
Marvel is like everything is connected
and then you find out later that it's
not really that connected Marvel did
just announced though they're dropping
the first big Doctor Strange trailer
next week ahead of Captain America Civil
War so we get new footage next week then
they'll probably drop another new one
with different footage when Civil War
actually does hit theaters it's not just
dr. strange there's a whole bunch of
Captain America stuff happening next
week too so get really hype about that
in tonight on arrow they are going to
reveal which character they're killing
there's a flash video that I've been
waiting to do that I just decided to
push because it depends on the character
that dies and tonight's hair just be
sure to watch arrow tonight because
people are going to go crazy for so many
different reasons it is going to be
spectacular I've never been more excited
to watch Twitter burn to the ground
tonight so new arrow video coming
tonight then I'll do a flash bonus video
that will explain some of what's going
on with the arrow WTF stuff a lot lots
of exciting stuff happening tonight well
you guys wait for me to post that video
tonight you can click here for my Doctor
Strange behind-the-scenes video they
just dropped a whole bunch of stuff and
you can click here for my captain
america vs black panther clip thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
five I'll see you guys tonight
you